MRA difficult game yesterday another
very difficult game today but the result
was definitely in your uh favor in this
one because you managed to save an
incredibly difficult position against
one of the best players on the planet
how are you feeling right
now yeah it feels nice to save this game
the last two games I like I had draws in
both of them just I had no time right
that was one thing I tried to I tried to
fix today I tried to keep more time on
the clock absolutely and of course I
there's I'm pretty sure yeah at some
point he was winning like after Queen
takes E5 and so on but it it kind of
shows that there's so much scope of
improvement at all levels it was all
about this moment at this point when you
guys were in this melee tactical melee
at this point and you played Bishop to
F4 we were a bit puzzled about this
decision because Queen to F5 made a lot
of sense when you played Bishop to F4
Queen que to F5 was definitely on your
radar did you calculate Queen to G4 was
that it was that your plan all
along yeah Queen G4 was one idea and
Knight D2 was another main idea
otherwise of course there's no point of
this yeah but I thought the issue there
was one or two issues with this I think
Bishop E6 was the main issue here mhm
because after Bishop E6 I just don't
have I actually don't have a move if I
go Bishop G3 or H2 he goes Queen C2 if I
go Bishop uh Bishop E3 he has Queen
takes C5 Knight F3 Queen E4 Knight D2
Queen C2 Bishop takes B6 Rook takes D2
and I thought like Queen E1 Queen takes
B2 and this looked quite difficult to
play because now Bish A5 Rook Rook F2 is
hanging and Rook B Rook B1 he has Queen
C3
yes and you're losing this one as well
this one is not looking good so you
decided on Queen G So based on that uh
yeah Queen G4 actually when I played
Bishop 4 at first I I saw of course I
saw Queen F5 Queen G4 and here there's
basically two choices for black queen C2
and queen takes G4 yeah now Queen takes
Queen C2 my original idea was to go
Knight E3 Queen takes B2 Bishop takes H6
that's what we thought as well
yes yeah yeah if this works of course I
would play this but the issue is Queen
takes A1 check King H2 and
now the the main point of this position
is at the automatic move G6 fails to
Queen H4 that's right and there's mid
yes so based on this okay like I I of
course I had to check this out more but
the thing is black has King f8 instead
of G6 mhm yeah very nicely calculated
King to f8 Queen takes G7 and now you go
king to8 queen takes G7 King E8 and now
here maybe you can try C4 that's right
like I'm not like it's one idea is now
you're turning Queen h8 check King D7 E6
but I think here maybe black can go uh
maybe but Queen D4 is one can to move
but Queen D4 you have Knight F5 like
maybe this this maybe this somehow works
but I don't I don't believe in this at
all it was Queen to A3 at this point I
think the very unpleasant move to face
ah ah yes this is a nice move you just
stop stop all counterplay and this I
mean this has to be winning for black
yeah yeah no absolutely and uh well you
decided to go for Rook to F1 and you got
to this
position and then how did you feel about
your chances at this point because to
our eyes it looked very
very bad C5 C4 was coming very quickly
and we didn't see a good way for you to
stop
it yeah it looks quite Grim for white
because the queen on H4 it actually just
has no squares right other than E7
there's like I I don't think there's a
single Square I can move it I can move
the queen without hanging it I think uh
maybe Rook D3
is or is he played Bishop B6 right at
some point instead of yes I think he
should have maybe kept the bishop on B3
I think C5 was maybe
perhaps more precise here C5 C4 mhm mhm
C5 C4 but still okay it's not it's not
too easy because somewhere the whole
point of this ship takes H6 was that now
there's always some Perpetual like you
can never play say Rook D3 in piece
because maybe somewhere have Queen C8
check yeah yeah without the6 that's a
defensive piece as well it protects your
uh King very
nicely yes and here maybe I can go H4 C4
H5 but okay like this should be quite
lost yeah and then you guys he allowed
you to uh enter this end game after d
exchange of the Rooks maybe a bit
prematurely for him did you understand
that this position is just
equal yeah actually I think I what I
spoke to him after the game I think he
he said F6 he missed like F3 because
after F6 F3 okay I get my queen on H4
finally gets some more breathing space
and now like Rook e one is all already a
threat and now the thing is since he's
played F6 his King is also going to be
quite weak and and now the queen side is
also this bishop on V6 is a really good
piece because now I just it kind of like
shuts down the queen side for now yeah
and if I ever get Rook E1 like now next
move Bishop A5 will be a threat right
due to the hanging Bishop on E6 yeah so
I think already around F3 I was kind of
getting a little bit more optimistic
like about my drawing chances yeah and
yeah this opposite CL Bishop ending I
thought it might be a bit trick but I
felt like in general it should be a draw
there's kind of two ways I can try to
hold this one idea is what to do what I
did in the game and bring the king to
the king side and start pushing pawns
the other idea is try to keep the King
on D4 and hold it like that I think the
one you did was pretty
practical yes because another issue is
that okay you put the King on D4 you
have to keep thinking every move yeah no
like here okay you you you kind of get a
force line and this is quite drawn but
the thing is uh like if I do if I if I
keep the King on D4 and say somehow my
king side gets frozen it might seem like
it's for example say like in the in the
worst and worst possible scenarios if I
have to go F4 G3 H4 mhm I think that
this might just be lost because uh with
the pawns on say like G6 F5 black can
keep the King on D6 and say my king will
be on B4 or D4 he can keep if my king is
on D4 he just has to cover the C4 square
and to too many pawns on the board
basically and at some point yeah yes you
will get in trouble no I think you took
the right decision very good practical
decisions along the way it wasn't easy
but I have to say I was impressed with
your defense so congratulations go get
some rest don't do too much training
after a five hour game don't do too much
training and we'll see you tomorrow it
was an honor to play against a legend
like Dominguez I've I've grown up
watching his games and he's simply one
of the best players in the world
absolutely absolutely congratulations M
seriously uh a very very big result uh
difficult opponent and it was a